bonjour à tous figaro live nous sommes
en direct sur lefigaro.fr et sur notre
page youtube figaro live pour suivre en
direct et commenté l'hommage national
rendu aux derniers compagnons de la
libération
il s'appelait donc hubert germain cette
figure de la résistance est décédé à
l'âge de 101 ans il était donc le
dernier des 1038 compagnon de la
libération
engagé dans la résistance auprès du
général de gaulle la cérémonie militaire
d'honneurs funèbres doit démarrer d'ici
quelques minutes dans une dizaine de
minutes elle se déroulera donc dans la
cour des invalides et sera présidée par
le chef de l'état emmanuel macron qui
doit d'ailleurs prononcé un discours un
éloge funèbre dans le studio à côté de
moi grégoire thonnat bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes donc auteur et directeur de la
collection du petit quiz des éditions
pierre de tayac et vous avez écrit
d'ailleurs deux petits quizz fort à
propos en ce jour donc l'un sur les
compagnons de la libération et l'autre
sur la treizième dbl donc c'était la
brigade de légion étrangère dont étaient
issues baer germain et donc ils sont à
paraître mi novembre et vous allez
pouvoir nous éclairer donc sur sur cette
figure de la résistance qui vient de
s'éteindre on va on va y revenir mais
tout d'abord donc avec la mort du bien
du bergère mince et c'est une page on va
dire de l'histoire de france qui se
tourne est ce qu'on peut qualifier
hébert germain de monuments de
l'histoire française
j'ai lu pour avoir dû changer je sais
pas si l'arrêt mais ce genre de terme
mais il est vrai que c'est vous l'avez
dit c'est une page qui se tourne c'est
le dernier des compagnons de la
libération les compagnons de la
libération ce sont les premiers des
premiers résistants ce sont 75 % ceux
qui ont été décorés de la croix de
libération s'engage avait enfin 40 et 4
91% s'engage à 20 42 donc ce sont les
tout premiers résistants ce sont eux qui
s'engage lorsque alors que tout est
perdu et qu'il n'y a pas d'espoir voilà
donc il est le dernier de cela alors si
vous nous rejoignez n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions si vous avez des
questions à poser ou des commentaires à
faire à propos de ce direct j'ai mon
ordinateur devant moi et c'est pour ça
je vous lis je vous regarde donc
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions à
nos à nos invités quel est ce qu'on peut
dire que les compagnons de la libération
enfin l'ordre de la libération c'est le
va dire la distinction suprême alors
l'armée au niveau hiérarchique vous avez
2 les deux principaux sens c'est d'abord
la légion d'honneur et après lors de la
libération alors lors de la libération
il a quand même une petite différence
c'est qu'il est forclos fermé depuis
1946 depuis janvier 46 à dire qu'il n'ya
eu que me vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
1038 personnes il faut rajouter à ça
qu'il ya eu 18 unités militaires et cinq
villes qui ont été fait compagnon
libération et à partir du janvier 46 et
2 exceptions avec le roi george e le roi
d'angleterre pardon j'ai oublié son nom
c'est sûr je dois recettes je sais plus
faisait pas de bêtises et winston
churchill et donc
il y as en dehors de en fait c'est un an
c'est un peu comme un ordre chevallier
si vous voulez voilà donc la libéra la
légion d'honneur est toujours décerné
ces cumuls ah oui on peut être on peut
être décoré des deux même plus que ça
bien sûr oui il me semble que hubert
vernet avait d'ailleurs beaucoup
beaucoup de distinctions dont là les
joueurs wii dans es 12 heures il était
cité à l'ordre de l'armée enfin il a
fait plus et puis après il ya une autre
carrière que à part la guerre il a une
carrière évidemment d'hommes politiques
il était ministre deux fois voilà alors
bonjour à christian coumba qui nous
rejoint sur le chat de youtube merci de
nous suivre en direct dans quelques
instants donc nous serons en direct
depuis l'hôtel des invalides pour suivre
cet hommage national rendu à hubert
germain est ce que vous avez eu
l'occasion grégoire thonnat de deux
rencontres et hubert germain alors je ne
vais pas rencontré mais j'ai eu
l'occasion le en juin dernier le en juin
2021 de participer à un échange
téléphonique avec lui parce que j'étais
à l'époque en immersion à la 13e des
bleus et le chef de corps
à cette occasion là à souhaiter à
appeler une bergère maintenant quand il
a eu un échange avec l'ue auquel on
assistait ainsi plusieurs légionnaires
qui venait d'être naturalisé français
donc il m'a fait cet honneur de pouvoir
assister à ça et voilà il était fatigué
bien évidemment mais je peux raconter
une petite anecdote puisque le chef de
corps au moment de la conversation a
démarré un peu lentement et voilà et au
bout d'un moment le chef de corps le dit
vous savez mon lieutenant on a des
photos de vous partout sur le camp et
sûrs germain a dit mais j'espère bien
mon colonel on s'est dit qu'il avait
quand même record que parce qu'il est ce
petit trait d'humour si vous a fait bien
évidemment rigoler tout d'une petite
réparti
a souligné vous évoquez donc la 13e dbl
donc vous êtes rendus sur place sur le
plateau du larzac ferrer l'immersion
j'ai eu cette chance d'être en immersion
plusieurs jours pour écrire votre
absolument et qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
alors de cette demi brigade
attention leur mission aujourd'hui
combien sont ils alors ils sont
actuellement ils sont environ 1300 sur
plateau du larzac enfin ça bouge un peu
puisque et des compagnies qui bouge
c'est il faut le dire quand même c'est
une d un des onze régiment de la légion
étrangère 1 c'est un régiment alors il a
des gens qui a plusieurs surnoms
notamment le régime en haussant
compagnon parce qu'il compte non pas 100
mais 98 compagnon on l'appelle aussi la
phalange magnifique et c'est un régiment
qui a été créé en février 40 à sidi bel
abbès et qui est parti très vite
combattre parce qu'en fait on dit à
l'ats 13 que à 21 jours de formation ont
suivi vingt-et-une années de combat
c'est à dire que de 40 jusqu'à la guerre
d'algérie la fin de la guerre d'algérie
ils n'ont cessé d'être de tous les
combats en afrique en europe en
indochine et en algérie voilà donc en
fait ils sont en permission il faut
rappeler aussi autre chose c'est que
c'est un des régiments qui il a perdu
trois chefs de corps au feu a mis le
lieutenant colonel ahmed al madjbari
pardon qui est mort à la mène
le lieutenant colonel gabriel de serigne
dont une des journalistes ici près de 20
qui était une des journalistes du figaro
guillemette de série ni pardon
il est mort en 48 en indochine et le
lieutenant et où le colonel gauche et
qui est mort à dien bien phu sur un des
points d'appui
de la bataille de dien ben phu est
aujourd'hui sont engagés ou alors du
coup bah ils sont oui sont au mali ils
ont participé récemment aux 6 av j
pirates
c'est un immense gisement de choc donc
ils sont au contact ce qu'on appelle au
contact donc oui sont allés plusieurs
fois au mali il s'en est bien évidemment
à auparavant en afghanistan
voilà c'est un régiment d'élite ils
seront évidemment présent aux invalides
peut-être pas les 1000 ha non non non
non pas vraiment mais le chef de corps
le colonel aubry sera évidemment présent
puisqu'on en terre un des leurs en fait
donc c'est
hubert germain c'est l'une des icônes du
régiment faut frapper et puis il a lors
de la bataille emblématique de
bir-hakeim il a été il a fait preuve
d'un courage il était d'ailleurs
récompensé puisqu'il a été citée à
l'ordre de l'armée peu après la bataille
de bir hakeim donc
donc voilà alors justement vous dit
qu'il a défendu son pays dans pas mal de
doutes et de terrain ibères germain donc
que vous parliez de la cibi de la libye
il ya également la syrie et l'egypte est
aussi beau mâle de bataille en france
est ce que c'est un destin exceptionnel
au sein des compagnons de la libération
où c'est un destin commun en fait alors
si vite par avoir travaillé puisque vous
l'avez dit je travaille aussi pour le
musée de l'ordre de la libération si
vous regardez le parcours alors je les
ai pas tous lui mais j'ai le
dictionnaire avec toutes les bio chaque
parcours est incroyable chaque parcours
est incroyable vous avez un jeune garçon
qui s'appelle laser pico itx qui était
fait compagnon de la libération à 17 ans
qui a été raflé au vel d'hiv il avait 13
ans il rentrait dans un réseau de
résistance il a été une première fois
par les allemands il s'échappe il est
arrêté une deuxième fois par la milice
il s'échappe encore et les décors et 17
ans voilà vous avez un autre parcours
comme roland de la poype qui est
aviateurs qui lui va combattre sur le
front russe dans une escale rick est
devenu évidemment célèbre qu'elle est ce
qu'elle aille normandie niemen déjà le
pour rejoindre son escadrille sur le
front russe en soi c'est une épopée il
est fait sûrs aux rôles une once avait
dit quand par joseph staline en personne
bon chacun de ces parcours et alors il
ya aussi des femmes peu mais il ya aussi
des femmes des gens comme berty albrecht
qui sont enterrés au mont valérien oui
chacun sait des parcours de vie
incroyable c'est des personnages
romanesques un oui oui je suis mérite
enfin pourrait faire des séries de leur
vie hilbert germain et d'autres bien sûr
tout à fait dedans vous en avez des très
connu vous avez pierre messmer qui était
premier ministre ministre vous avez
jacques chaban delmas vous avez romain
gary
c'est vrai quand même l'avant dernier
sur violent daniel caudron décédé il ya
passé quelques mois quelques mois oui
l'hiver dernier je sais plus exactement
il a aussi eu un hommage national des
moustiques qui était un type que là pour
le coup j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
plusieurs fois qu'était un type
extraordinaire ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que je les ai vu un an ou
deux ans sa mort il avait fait encore
des conférences au musée d'or il avait
une énergie une énergie dans sa voie il
était et moi il m'avait impressionné
d'abord c'est un bon vieux monsieur très
élégant et ils continuaient à passer ses
messages là pour rappeler que ça a été
le secrétaire et le radio jean moulin à
lyon pendant l'occupation donc il a
partagé plusieurs mois de la
clandestinité de jean moulin
on s'en souvient oui effectivement
l'éloge funèbre de vue président aussi a
abordé beaucoup à ce parcours
extraordinaire j'imagine que l'éloge
funèbre qu'hubert germain aura tout à
l'heure également par le président de la
république reviendra sur surtout surtout
cette histoire extraordinaire
qu'il a vécue d'ailleurs sur le sur le
site du figaro donc le papier écrit donc
l'article écrit par etienne de montety
son portrait on va dire qui a été publié
il ya beaucoup de des loges et de
commentaires élogieux qui ont été
publiées sur sur notre site
et effectivement c'est mérité un toutes
ces éloges quelles sont les valeurs que
représente on va dire hubert germain
alors on peut dire les valeurs des
compagnons de la résistance les
compagnons de génération
en fait c'est le refus de l'adversité
alors quand tout est perdu et ben en
fait il ya sept derrière et ce sont des
valeurs de patriotisme de patriotisme
bas même si tout est perdu ben on
continue et on va de l'avant voilà et
c'est ce qui caractérise ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est ce qui
caractérise les compagnons de la
libération c'est tous ces gens là ce
sont des gens qui s'engagent alors que
la guerre est vraiment perdu houle où on
est aux mondiaux au fond du gouffre et
ils vont quand même voilà au bord du
précipice ah non ils sont dedans en juin
40 l'état de la france il est quand même
catastrophique c'est une chute qu'on n'a
jamais connu dans l'histoire de france
et puis détail a plus rien voilà et
malgré tout ça lui de hubert germain le
24 juin il était élève il était en
classe préparatoire pour rentrer à
l'école navale et le 24 juin 40 en fait
ils passent pas son concours il se dit
bah non c'est pas possible et en fait
ils s'embarquent sur un bateau dans le
sud de la france je crois à
saint-jean-de-luz il part en angleterre
et donc il s'engage dans la france libre
fin juin 1940 alors qu' il n'avait pas
fini ses études rien n'était il était
donc il était né en 1920 donc il avait
20 ans
c'est dingue à 20 ans de prendre c'est
c'est cette décision on va dire beaucoup
de liart je crois que c'est de 10% des
compagnons de la libération ont 20 ans
ou moins de 20 ans
et un peu c'est que c'est une décision
qu'ils y voient la sas et puis comment
par la jeunesse d'un coup alors ça
s'explique alors c'est une question
intéressante une grande partie des
compagnons de la libération
ce sont des gens qui sont diplômés en
fait du bac à lorient dire qu'ils ont un
niveau on re si tu le jour contexte en
1939 crois qu'il ya à peu près de 10% de
la population call back je crois que
plus de 50% des compagnons ont le bac
c'est à dire que ce sont des gens qui
sont éduqués et donc l'éducation elle
prime la dent ça c'est un premier point
le second point bas c'est les valeurs
patriotiques qui baigne dans un climat
dans un milieu familial qui évidemment
nourris de ce patriotisme la sas et sa
c2
deux constantes qu'on trouve chez les
compagnons de la libération hubert
germain était issu d'une famille de
militaires s'est pour sa part été
officier général tout à fait voilà donc
ça explique ça explique peut-être son
patriotisme il ya plus que du
patriotisme il ya quand même de
l'abnégation fin
du sacrifice en fait de se sacrifier
pour la france à 20 ans alors imagine
beaucoup moins les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
de 20 ans de se sacrifier à sa fin alors
je prends la france sont ces
photons c'est pas parce que vous savez
c'est une circonstance aussi qu'ils font
ça je n'en n'ai pas confrontés à une
situation aujourd'hui même si la
situation actuelle est compliquée on vit
pas l'effondrement quand même complet
d'une société comme on a pu le connaître
en juin quand c'est difficile de
comprendre et d imaginer ça maintenant
il ya aussi la fougue de la jeunesse
il ya beaucoup de gens qui s'engagent en
fait qu'ils n'ont qui ne sont pas charge
de famille c'est quand même c'est comme
quand vous êtes vous êtes père de
famille vous avez x enfants à charge une
société un métier tu sais c'est pas
simple il y en a qui le font mais vous
regardez aussi bien plus de choses à
perdre la moitié des compagnons viennent
sont onze sont aussi des militaires
alors s'il n'était pas militaire en tant
que tel en juin 40 ici destinait
puisqu'il devait être marin y vient
d'une famille de militaires son père est
générale voilà donc ça va plus ça va
plus ça fait que ça fait cet engagement
là daniel cordier qui était à bordeaux
aussi qu'ils embarquent à
saint-jean-de-luz donc sans doute pas
très loin de là où hubert germain a
embarqué lui il était il était
royalistes en fait ils venaient les
camelots du roi donc il était
nationaliste royalistes et après il
évoluera d'ailleurs dans la vie il l'a
expliqué très bien dans son dans ses
livres qui a fait plusieurs livres
remarquables julien loger merci d'avoir
laissé un commentaire sur sur notre chat
youtube qui nous dit impressionnant la
solidité de ces hommes et de ces femmes
qui en fin de vie ont toujours leur tête
après tout ce qu'ils ont vécu d'intenses
et vous confirmez donc grégoire thonnat
vous qui avez assisté à donc à cet
échange téléphonique
c'était il ya un an donc il avait 100
ans c'est ça ouais rien en ce mois de
juin un mois de juin et donc il a réussi
à avoir une certaine répartie on va dire
oui oui oui mais en fait vous savez ce
qui caractérise le si ces gens là parce
que j'en ai rencontré d'autres d'abord
c'est une vraie humilité allez pas
feinte c'est une vraie humilité et ça
pour en avoir rencontré quand même un
certain nombre
on retrouve sache et tous ces gens là
j'ai eu l'occasion de connaître un autre
personnage qu'il y avait qui a une vie
aussi pas banal qui s'appelait bernard
dargols qu'il ya des gages qui a
débarqué en france où l'uniforme
américain les hasards de la vie ont fait
qui s'est retrouvé dans l'armée
américaine voilà et quand il me
racontait je fais surfer déjeuner avec
lui assez long et jeu je posais la
question j mais c'est quoi votre
camp vous avez débarqué il a débarqué en
juin en juin 44 en normandie donc c'est
un endroit où c'était quand même un peu
compliqué et en fait il restait très
simple il y avait beaucoup d'humour par
rapport à ça alors qu'on sait qu'il a vu
et vécu des choses très dures à battre
est un événement très dur hubert germain
avait des choses très dures la bataille
de bir hakeim c'est terrible est-ce
qu'on peut revenir un petit peu sur cet
épisode pour ceux qui la bataille de bir
hakeim c'est dans le désert de lybie
effectivement c'était un point de
défense qui fait partie du système mis
en place par les britanniques au sein
duquel sont intégrés ce qu'on appelle la
1re dfl première division française
libre hausse au sein duquel est la
treizième dbl faux faux faux je rentre
un peu dans les détails voilà et eux
c'est un point de défense est en fait
ils font un point de fixation pour
empêcher les troupes
italiennes et allemandes menée par le
général rommel d'aller vers vers
l'egypte est donc évidemment de
contrôler l'egypte le canal de suez etc
et donc ça c'est un point de fixation et
pendant une quinzaine de jours de entre
fin mai et début juin et donc les
français combat alors à je suis pas si
c'est un contredit j'ai pu en tête les
chiffres mais en fait c'est un vrai fait
d'armes c'est un fait d'armes majeur et
il a le général de gaulle d'ailleurs le
souligne j'ai plus la phrase pourrait la
retrouver et feignies fait une
déclaration à ce moment-là mal à mener
de bir-hakeim
mais c'est un retentissement mondial et
ils marquent très dans les médias de
l'époque le retour de la france dans la
guerre parce qu'on sait que ce sont des
français qui dans le désert libyen en
fait ce top l'avancé des italiens et des
allemands menés par romaine et ça ça
marque le retour de la france dans la
guerre ça redonne une impulsion c'était
une impulsion intérêt à cette résistance
il faut rappeler que jusqu'à cette date
alors il ya eu d'autres épisodes un peu
avant mais celui là il a un
retentissement médiatique majeur
la campagne de 40 qui a été terrible
pour l'armée française la drôle de
guerre et puis mai juin 40 en fait c'est
évidemment ce ne sont que des défaites
même s'il ya des des défenses héroïques
voilà il faut rappeler aussi que la
troisième des pme dont est issu hubert
germain qui elle va combattre les
allemands en norvège on dit de la 13e db
le qu'elle a remporté les deux seules
victoires des campagnes de 39 et 40
parce que ils ont pris deux villes de
norvège la plus connue étant narvik et
ça c'est mené par des légionnaires de la
13ème dble alors gilbert germaneau n'y
étaient pas il y était parfaite et à bir
hakeim il établit un qui aime bien sûr
alors vous voyez en direct ces images
donc des invalides de l'hôtel des
invalides parisien
on devrait attendre j'imagine dans
quelques instants le président de la
république on a vu juste avant donc le
premier ministre jean castex mais
également la ministre des armées
florence parly et la secrétaire d'état
aux armes et geneviève darrieussecq
edouard philippe qui est là en tant que
ancien premier ministre évidemment c'est
un lot mais
c'est un hommage national
est alors ces écharpes bleues qu'est ce
qu'elle représente il ya un mystère il
ya c'est pas des couleurs de la région
puisque des couleurs de la légion il
faut le rappeler c'est le vert dont on
voit les cravates du drapeau là des
porte drapeaux du porte drapeau c'est
vert et rouge donc cette cravate cette
écharpe bleue c'est chef bleu je ne sais
pas et je vois là un cui on n'a pas la
réponse de ce gang des écharpes bleues
je vais demander un petit peu de retours
sont pour que nous dans le studio on
puisse entendre
voilà donc c'est certainement l'arrivée
du convoi du président
il
et alors cette grande cour du du palais
des invalides
l'hôtel des invalides l'hôtel des
invalides où se déroulent toujours les
hommages nationaux oui historiquement et
depuis on va dire depuis le retour des
cendres de napoléon en 1840 ça a été le
lieu des grands hommages nationaux
principalement d'uniterre
on va écouter
[Musique]
passage en revue des troupes
voilà
[Musique]
ans
voilà
[Applaudissements]
m
allez
[Musique]
au
repos
car la gamme
présentée
au
[Musique]
de la 13ème dble comporter oui son
cercueil sur les dernières chefs d'état
vous avez
bâti ce qui est l'actuel patron de
l'ordre de libération
et ancien
directeur du musée de l'armée
reposez
rencontre
prononcer l'éloge funèbre
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président du sénat
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame et messieurs les premiers
ministres
madame l'ambassadrice
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
monsieur le grand chancelier de la
légion d'honneur
monsieur le délégué national mesdames et
messieurs les membres du conseil de
l'ordre de la libération
monsieur le chef d'état-major des armées
officiers sous-officiers officiers
mariniers soldats quartiers maîtres et
matelots aviateurs
mesdames et messieurs en vo degré et
qualité mesdames et messieurs
la vie d'hubert germain
est une anthologie d'engagement et de
courage
avec les mille trente sept compagnons de
la libération
qui voit là 80 ans ont relevé la france
de la bim
il forma un ordre fraternelle
une phalange de l'idéal
à l'aube qu'au crépuscule
il fut le dernier à rendre les armes
résistant de la première heure et ultime
héros de ce cercle de combattants
désormais disparu
déracinés par les pérégrinations d'un
père générale en syrie et en indochine
hubert germain n'aimait rien tant que de
retrouver ses terres de la drôme
et passa sa jeunesse à chercher la
france partout
dans les livres dans ses rêves
adolescents
ses frasques inquiéter sa famille ils
étaient indisciplinés en tout d'une
insoumission farouche qui ne se
connaissait qu'une fidélité
la patrie
tout commence au printemps 1940
alors que pétain vient de signer
l'armistice
il passe le concours de l'école navale
et tandis qu'il compose sur la table
d'examen
une révélation
réussir le conduire est d'asservir une
armée aux ordres de l'allemagne nazie
alors le voilà qui se lèvent
refuse d'achever son travail
et déclare
je pars faire la guerre
la fougue du berger remet un
heureusement en rencontre d'autres car
s'il quitte ses amis sa famille il
trouve en angleterre d'autres amis une
autre famille qui ont répondu comme lui
à l'appel du général de gaulle
à londres ils sont quelques centaines
une guilde de l'honneur
prête à tout pour une cause qui les
dépasse
la france libre
paysans artisans
instituteur soldats ils deviennent
camarades pour la vie
ils sont aujourd'hui compagnon
d'éternité
à l'été londonien succèdent pour hubert
germain les printemps levantin
lui qui brûle de se battre est d'abord
envoyé sur le front de syrie et à l'été
c'est en libye qu'il se couvre de gloire
de gaulle demande à ses soldats de
ralentir l'avancée des troupes de rommel
vers l'egypte en tenant le verrou de bir
hakeim toute la france vous regarde vous
êtes son orgueil leur dit il
la chaleur est harassante le vent
charrie le sable hubert germain et ses
compagnons de la troisième demi brigade
de légion étrangère érige malgré tout
sur la route de l'ennemi un barrage
impénétrable un contre dix
peu importe
durant 16 jours
il résiste à tous les assauts du ciel et
de la terre lancé contre eux
miracle de la volonté prodige du
patriotisme
soirée féerique car dans la nuit du 10
au 11 juin 1940 2 le bouclier
impénétrable se mue en une colonne
d'irréductibles qui finit par briser
l'encerclement ennemis
et c'est hubert germain en flammes et de
courage qui prend la tête des troupes en
cette nuit d'apocalypse
il est alors pour eux une torche dans
l'obscurité
sa détermination est plus incandescente
que les fusées qui zèbrent le ciel au
milieu des lignes allemandes
l'épopée de la france libre ne s'arrête
pas là et le mène ensuite au pied des
pyramides d'égypte en tunisie en italie
il voit mourir sous ses yeux
tant de frères d'armes qui ne quittait
jamais son esprit
il est blessé al'approche de monte
cassino mais continue malgré tout
toujours
pour se voir accrocher tout près du
coeur des mains mêmes du général de
gaulle la croix qui le fait compagnon
dans l'ordre de la libération
l'honneur et la mission d'une vie
hubert germain sait qu'il doit s'en
montrer digne à jamais
enfin vient le jour sonne l'heure de
retrouver son pays
le 15 août 1944 hubert germain débarque
sur les plages de provence
ce jour là
son premier geste est de s'agenouiller
pour prendre un peu de la terre de
france dans ses mains
la sentir la touche et
retrouvailles charnel
après quatre ans de combat et d'exil
il se relève encore et sa patrie avec
lui remonte le rhône rejoints le rhin
libère l'alsace gagne berlin avant enfin
de
revenir
quelques années à peine après avoir
quitté les théâtres militaires
hubert germain entrera dans l'arène
politique
en devenant maire de saint chéron petit
bourg de l'essonne qui hurlent les rives
de l'orge fidèles de de gaulle est
proche de messmer ils portent leurs
idées les siennes jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale d'abord dans les rangs du
gouvernement ensuite
ministre des postes télégraphes et
téléphones puis ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement sous la
présidence de georges pompidou
avec ses frères d'armes
il avait défendu la liberté
avec ses frères d'âme
toutes celles et ceux qui se
reconnaissent comme tel il allait
désormais rebâtir la fraternité
quête inlassable
d'une vie de résistance et d'espérance
ces dernières années
hubert germain était devenu le gardien
du flambeau qu'avait allumé le général
de gaulle
ultime reconnaissance de ses frères
d'armes il avait été fait caporal-chef
d'honneur de la légion étrangère
il ya quelques semaines
dernier chancelier d'honneur de l'ordre
de la libération
il en a attisé les braises ardentes
jusqu'à son dernier souffle
elle ne s'éteindront pas avec lui
hubert germain reposera dans la crypte
du mont valérien
scellant ainsi l'histoire des 1038
compagnon
nous avions des convictions
philosophiques politiques
et religieuses différentes
voire opposées
mais nous avons su nous rassembler pour
la cause sacrée de la liberté de notre
patrie tels étaient ses mots
alors oui
l'ordre de la libération lui survivra
indépendant et fidèle à son histoire
j'en fais ici le serment
mon lieutenant
ces derniers mois
vous avez livré votre ultime combat
votre courage et votre dignité face à la
mort sur une leçon pour nombre d'entre
nous
l'humilité et les doutes vous ont
accompagné
et vous êtes devenu chaque jour un peu
plus
l'incarnation même de tous vos
compagnons vibrant de cette flamme
première celle de l'amour de la france
et du service de la patrie
alors en ce jour
le silence millénaire de l'esprit de
résistance et de l'acharnement français
vous accompagne c'est cette cohorte
chevaleresque qui vient du fond des âges
de pâtes et de reims d'arcole et du
chemin des dames de la garde impériale à
koufra d'orléans à bir hakeim qui se
tient à vos côtés et nous rappelle cet
irrésistible résolution de la france
ne rien céder de la liberté de la patrie
et de son âme
voulait rejoignez un lieutenant
et notre tâche sera de poursuivre avec
la même ardeur ce combat
nous le ferons
vive la république
vive la france
key
car berlin
[Musique]
présenter up
aux morts
[Musique]
et
reposer
gardot
[Musique]
présentée au
e
oh
on
rejoignez nous sommes toujours en direct
donc sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube pour
cet hommage national rendu aux derniers
compagnons de la libération hébert
germain
dommage notamment dans le chat dans lé
chat sur lefigaro.fr et sur youtube je
vais en lire quelques-uns
jocelyne gentec ce qui est dit merci et
respect à tous ces hommes et femmes qui
par leur courage et leur détermination
ont sauvé la france nature montagne et
découvertes hommage à ce grand homme
mort pour la france solide 38 qui
déclare cet homme et la france respect
george washington là je comprends
pourquoi une cérémonie de cette ampleur
a été organisée c'était un grand homme
un héros et repart à paix à son âme
puisse-t-elle reposer aux côtés de tous
nos grands héros morts pour la france et
sur lefigaro.fr christian léo tous les
ans tous un pardon un internaute fidèles
de figaro live hommage à l'homme de la
résistance française combat pour
l'existence de la république
je
un ancien chef de corps de la trêve
cette cérémonie il a une double
importance pour lui puisqu'il a dirigé
cette unité au sein duquel était
sein duquel hébert germain combattu
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
donc les âmes de la 13e défaut de la
grèce bien sûr et légionnaires
et jeux sur les uniformes des autres les
autres unités notamment de l'armée de
l'air on voit qu'ils portent la
fourragère ce que disait tout à l'heure
il ya 18 unités militaires en france qui
ont été fait compagnon de la libération
l'a13 et une unité compagnon de
libération au sein duquel elle a à ce
titre
il ya 98
militaire légionnaires qui a été décoré
voilà mes donc là dans l'assemblée
les unités qui étaient là l'armée de
l'air donc je ne sais pas quelle est
cette unité mais c'est une unité qui est
compagnon de la libération puisque on
voit qu'il porte la fourragère verte qui
est symbole de ça c'est de la décoration
de l'unité qui était décoré de l'ordre
de la libération
et à ce propos grégoire thonnat sur les
sur les décorations il ya un internaute
qui nous pose une question directement
cède m 46 qui nous dit pourquoi ne pas
décorer ses soldats à leur vivant je ne
comprendrais jamais il a déclaré ça en
voyant donc justement toutes ses
décorations d'hébergement mais il les a
vues de son vivant bien sûr voilà sur
eux et il a été des copains il a été
honoré il ya quelques semaines par le
chef d'état major des armées du titre je
passe en face à du titre du grade de
caporal chef jean dagher faut savoir
qu'un officier de légion n'est pas
légionnaires seuls les légionnaires sont
légionnaires les caporaux qu'à part au
chef les les officiers et au sein de la
trêve c'est le cas ils sont français et
il encadre des étrangers puisque 80%
des légionnaires sont étrangers voilà
donc il a été décoré de son vivant bien
sûr et le chef de l'état dans son
discours là dit il a été décoré de la
croix de la libération tant qu'il a été
fait compagnon de la libération par le
général de gaulle en personne voilà il a
plusieurs autres médailles effectivement
on le voit le rouge de la légion
d'honneur puisqu'il est il est
commandeur de la légion d'honneur donc
tout ça a été fait évident a bien
évidemment de son vivant il est
également il a également reçu la croix
de guerre 34 oui logiquement quand vous
êtes complètement à la guerre et vous
voilà et en plus il a été cité à l'ordre
de l'armée il est médaillé de la
résistance qui est la 2e décoration en
fait de la résistance qui est j'ai
réussi par lors de la libération au sort
de la libération vous avez deux ordres
donc la croix de la libération et la
médaille de la résistance donc à 1038
compagnon donc berjamin et le dernier et
au sein des médaillés de la résistance
est là pour le coup ils iront il y en a
encore deux vivant il était je crois
environ 70 milles mais c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose quand même rappelons
que les compagnons de la libération ce
sont ceux qui s'engagent ce sont les
résistants de la première heure aussi
bien résistance extérieure c'était le
cas du berger un que résistance
intérieure puisque vous avez des gens
comme jean moulin pierre brossolette qui
ont été fait compagnon de la libération
une bonne partie je crois que c'est un
tiers là pour le coup la question
d'auditeurs ont été décoré à titre
posthume
voilà mais c'est pas le cas du père
germain
robert des aides sur le chat de youtube
qui dit toutes nos condoléances à sa
famille vive la liberté et vive la
france est donc ce tard mais ce gang des
chars bleus dont on ne sait pas quelle
est la signification c'est parce que
c'est là peut-être c'est des classes
européennes je sais pas du tout va sont
pas les couleurs enfin je le redis c'est
pas du tout les couleurs de la légion
puisque la légion sévère puisque on voit
la cravate verte et un écran vert et
rouge voir et là on voit on voit le
drapeau de la 13
qui porte le nom des principales
batailles de l'a13
ces dernières années sur ces 80
dernières années puisque c'est une unité
qu'à 80 un peu plus de 80 ans
christian léon toussaint sur lefigaro.fr
qui dit salut compagnon breuvage
immortel qui s'épanche en au coeur du
bord même des cieux
commentaires poétiques d'un internaute
peut-être que ce sont des élèves de
classes défense puisque vous savez
qu'elle est en france l'un des classes
défense je sais pas du tout
voit on voit les officiers là
effectivement de l'armée de terre avec
leur carte hardware donc ça c'est des
officier de légion
il n'y a que la légion qui est présent
non non non non non non vous savez tout
est à la marie donc voila voila voila
mais dans les dix huit unités donc je
pense que des représentants des 18
unités compagnon de la libération dont
vous avez des marins des aviateurs et
puis l'armée de terre bien évidemment
il
la mise de la défense
car aucun
présentée au
donc le drapeau de la 13e un gros plan
sur les 13
alors il ya une histoire que le drapeau
de la 13 c'est que
quand l'unité a été constitué la
pétition drapeau tout de suite et en
fait il a fallu une remise officielle de
drapeaux qui a lyon je crois que c est
en fait le chef de corps à l'époque
avait peur que le drapeau qui venait
d'angleterre quitté fabricant de
l'auteur n'arrive pour la remise la
cérémonie officielle et ce sont des
femmes françaises qui était au caire et
qui ont fabriqué qu'on cousue elle-même
le premier drapeau de l'unité qui
s'appelle donc apporter le drac est en
fait qui s'appelle le drapeau des femmes
du caire voilà donc l'unité a eu deux
drapeaux puisque le drapeau commander
est arrivée du chef fabricant enfin bon
on imagine ça en pleine guerre voilà on
voit le colonel aubry la gare de
drapeaux qui présentait à nos colonnes
le bruit
voilà qui porte les les noms et les
dates des principales batailleur la
première c'est pas la trêve puisque
c'est cameron mais c'est la bataille
emblématique de légion étrangère voilà
le colonel ouvriers
qui dirige alors le chef de corps ces
deux ans donc il est
il est
presque à la fin de son de son
commandement puisque ça allait
changement de commandement général c'est
en juin juillet ça dépend
vous voyez là effectivement tous les
noms ces principes du principal bataille
là de la seconde guerre mondiale qu'on a
vu à l'écran rapidement auquel a
participé une bergère main parce qu'il
était dans les combats de l'âme du
massif de l'authion 45 évidemment il
était à birac m il était en italie où
était blessé il a fait la
parole alors on lire en fait ils sont
pas battus à rome c'est pas mais ils ont
ils ont fait la campagne d'italie
étaient ils ont fait des combats très
durs d'ailleurs et il a été blessé en
menant une action assez courageuse il a
été blessé à cette occasion là pendant
la campagne dit-elle
une belle image
or à cause du
recours
car le
présenter à
vos ordres du commandant compris
donc le bruit les médailles de la
poitrine du chef de corps qui sans
tranchée
je pense que quand vous êtes il est
jeune et que vous êtes légionnaires de
treize épouses être là aujourd'hui c'est
quand même un jour très particulier quoi
n'importe qui va forcément rester dans
leur mémoire et forte raison pour le
chef de corps les officiers des
sous-officiers des légionnaires
alors qu'on voit valérie pécresse est
juste avant eric dupond moretti
il y avait d'autres ministres également
qu'ils étaient présents
l'ancien gouverneur ancien gouvernement
alors le cercueil est parti est ce qu'on
sait où est ce qu'ils veulent et inhumé
ce qui sera alors oui on sait où il va
être inhumé et ça ça sera le 11 novembre
en fait puisqu'en fait il va être inhumé
au au mont valérien au mémorial de la
france combattante 39-45 où il va
rejoindre 16 autres dépouilles d'autres
combattants de tous les fronts qui est
de soldats français ou résistants voilà
et donc sont le le cercueil enfin le
quel il va être effectivement enterré
l'attend depuis 1945 avait sa place à
bazas était réservé depuis et ça c'était
voulu par le général de gaulle donc
c'est lui qui a choisi de m'emballer
rien qui est un lieu de martyrs de la
résistance comme on sait puisqu'un
certain nombre de résistances fichiers
internes et fusillé là et donc c'est le
mont valérien c'est le mémorial de la
france combattante combattante pardon
voulu par le général de gaulle il faut
savoir que la flamme qui brûle sur
l'esplanade du mont valérien une flamme
qui brûle en permanence elle est ravivée
par la flamme de l'arc de triomphe donc
c'est la liaison entre la première la
seconde guerre mondiale et donc le 11
novembre il va être
et à nouveau avec les autorités et que
le chef de l'état il va être enterré aux
moules inhumé
au mémorial du mont valérien et il y
aura d'ailleurs comme vous vous disiez
juste avant le parallèle entre l'ap de
triomphe les deux guerres étaient en
parle on voit sur les tenues allez-y
vous voyez là effectivement les foires
gerwert donc d'unités compagnon de la
libération pardon
soucis donc vous vous disiez vous
faisiez lien entre les deux guerres et
effectivement je crois qu'il ya
d'ailleurs une première cérémonie
présidée à l'arc de triomphe gr une
inhumation voilà absolument oui c est un
peu exceptionnel
cette année évidemment
et le mont valérien donc pour ceux qui
savent passer à côté de paris rassurée
nouvelle assez dans les autres des
situations les plus hot de la région
parisienne voilà c'est dans les
hauts-de-seine oui tout à fait
alors
le mont valérien en général la grande
cérémonie ses 18 juin
hubert germain assistait le 18 juin
dernier a été dans un fauteuil roulant à
la cérémonie de mémoire de l'appel du 18
juin voilà pas ce combat c'est l'homme
du 18 juin il était à lille et rennes
étaient prêts on rappelle qu'ils
vivaient dans les têtes des invalides la
vivait dans l'hôtel des invalides et
d'ailleurs sur les images j'ai reconnu
le général de saint-chamas en fait qui
est le patron entre guillemets de
l'institut des invalides il faut
rappeler que les invalides qui a été
créée voulue par louis xiv et son
secrétaire de la défense le voir qui est
un hôpital et un lieu d'hébergement pour
les militaires âgés depuis le règne de
louis xiv est toujours un hôpital est
toujours une maison de retraite et qui
accueillent des anciens combattants mais
hiver germain était là depuis depuis
quelques années je sais pas depuis quand
enfin ils étaient ils habitaient en fait
aux avanies
vous êtes encore nombreux à témoigner en
tout cas à rendre hommage à hubert
germain sur sur le chat de youtube
notamment avec mehsud c'est grâce à des
gens comme comme ce monsieur que nous
vivons libre et beaucoup de messages de
condoléances également de condoléances
pour pour lui et sa famille sur les 2
les deux chat les deux forums
belle image la cour d'honneur sous le
soleil c'est alors tout à l'heure je
vous ai coupé justement sur les
invalides pourquoi les hommages
nationaux sont toujours
organisés on va dire dans la basse et
autres satellites sont devenues
progressivement importé aux militaires
et puis depuis 1840 avec le retour des
cendres de napoléon donc qui est sous le
dôme est donc régulièrement évidemment
tous les grands militaires ont été
symboliquement enterré là alors il ya
vous avez des gouverneurs vous savez que
vous avez rouget de lisle le créateur la
marseillaise qui est enterré
provisoirement depuis quand même certain
nombre d'années dans le caveau des
gouverneurs voilà et donc tous les
grands hommages nationaux ont lieu
dans la cour d'honneur des invalides
king qui répond aussi qu'un terme
pratique est assez d'abord elle est
imposante elle est magnifique en plus
c'est un lieu fermé donc en termes de
sécurité c'est pas c'est plus
intéressant on est il n'y a pas d'erreur
on est dans un coussin d'un panthéon
militaires voient la fauche a été
enterré dalle leclerc été enterrés là le
général de brigade de la traite et
intérêts la
les parachutistes qui ont été tuées dans
l'attentât du drakkar au liban au début
des années 80 il ya une immense je me
souviens de cette cérémonie j'étais
jeune mais il y avait je crois que c'est
58 soldats 58 cercueils qui étaient dans
cette cour voilà et puis on a élargi et
plus récemment puisque simone veil jean
d'ormesson aussi gloire nationale ont
été enterrés là et tout récemment il ya
quelques jours en comptant sur une belle
blonde au chalet brand voilà
effectivement
on élargit les zonards j'y vois là c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite ville pas une
polémique mais des gens qui ont fait
leur marque en tant qu on avait mis le
drapeau français comme pour hubert
germain sur le cercueil de belmondo bon
voilà enfin bébel s'étaient bébel donc
je tiens personnage tellement
sympathique et qui a fait rayonner
de la france dans le monde entier voilà
patrick blanc je continue de vous lire
dans le chat et vous êtes nombreux
patrick blanc qui dit qui nous fait part
de dire d'une idée il faudrait instaurer
un hommage à tous les résistants de la
part des écoliers en se rendant dans les
cimetières de leur commune où sont
enterrés des anciens combattants bon
alors il ya un certain nombre
d'associations certains pourquoi vous
déjà ça non mais vous avez dix
associations patrick qui gère ça pour le
11 novembre
notamment je pense à ça parce que ce
métal est de participer souvent dans les
écoles on emmène les enfants autour du
monument aux morts avant une cérémonie
particulière ça se fait aussi déjà donc
quand laurence devant ça se faisait pour
le oui mais ça se fait aussi ça existe
déjà mais mon parti c'est pas une idée
nouvelle patrick blanc
peut-être le systématiser le rendre
obligatoire peut-être c'est un peu au
bon vouloir on va dire des directions
direct oui je sais pas comment c'est
gérer sa vie en france
tout tout tout est compliqué si vous
nous rejoignez donc nous venons de
suivre et d'assister en direct à
l'hommage national rendu aux derniers
combattants aux derniers compagnons de
la libération donc aux derniers
résistants de la seconde guerre mondiale
hubert germain les images qui est qui
nous provenaient viennent donc de
s'arrêter le cercueil est parti
maintenant il ya il ya plusieurs minutes
vous l'avez dit juste avant il sera
inhumé donc le 11 novembre au mont
valérien vous pourrez suivre d'ailleurs
cette cérémonie en direct sur figaro là
je vais remercier donc mon invité
grégoire thonnat séjour merci beaucoup
pour vos lumières vos éclairages sur
cette cette cérémonie je rappelle à tous
ceux qui nous regardent que vous êtes
auteur et directeur d'une collection qui
savait d'une collection des petits quizz
aux éditions pierre de tayac vous en
voyez par exemple je vais vous demander
à raphaël de remettre voilà trois
exemplaires on va dire qui concerne
directement le direct qu'on connaît
comme radio et l'a13 effectivement qui
vont sortir en librairie hasard du
calendrier qui vont sortir dans une
quinzaine de jours
voilà je vais je vais je vais terminer
on va dire ce direct par une par une
citation d'hubert germain qui a était
paru dans ce dans son livre espérer pour
la france écrit par marc leroy et
publiée il ya pas si longtemps que ça
aux belles lettres
alors cette citation je vais vous la
dire quand le dernier d'entre nous sera
mort la flamme c'est un drame et il
restera toujours des braises et il faut
aujourd'hui en france des braises
ardentes voilà je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi ce direct et je vous dis à très
vite pour un prochain direct sur figaro
live